olá pessoal tudo bem
é uma honra estar aqui falando com vocês
e bom
meu nome é guillermo novak e eu sou
desenvolvedor de realidade virtual e
estudante de psicologia fazem alguns
anos que eu venho estudando as
tecnologias que vai falar aqui hoje
essas ditas realidades digitais que são
na realidade virtual realidade aumentada
e realidade mista
eu queria trazer para vocês um pouco
dessas desse aprendizado que eu colhi e
ao longo do tempo das conclusões que eu
cheguei e da minha perspectiva pessoal
de como as tecnologias podem nos ajudar
então vou começar pela maior conclusão
que cheguei que essas realidades
digitais que vai falar que vão mudar o
nosso mundo jogos de realidade virtual
que vocês vêm por aí no shopping na
televisão na internet
eles têm o potencial de mudar o mundo
como a gente conhece hoje eu quero
explicar como isso vai acontecer mas
antes vou contar uma história
então eu sou uma pessoa extremamente
curiosa eu sempre vou atrás das coisas
que eu gosto tanto experimentar e fazer
coisas novas mas eu também tenho muito
muito medo de altura
então quando um lugar alto engraçado as
minhas pernas tremem eu fico ansioso eu
conheço tem aqueles pensamentos de que
vou caído em alguma coisa vai dar errado
mas a minha curiosidade sempre levou aí
lugares cada vez mais altos
tentar sempre desafiar e vencer seus
medos não é à toa que eu subi no segundo
o morro do pão de açúcar no rio de
janeiro ea 400 metros de altura
depois de ficar 15 minutos é colocado no
chão eu consegui me levantar gravar um
vídeo sair correndo e essa mesma
curiosidade me levou pra fazer uma coisa
que foi a experiência mais longa que já
fiz na minha vida então eu entrei no
avião subir a 500 metros de altura mil
metros de altura
mil e quinhentos metros de altura eu
estava aterrorizado basicamente em
pânico em cima pensando que eu ia cair
ali e eu ia sair dali porque eu saltei
desse avião uma lona amarrado nas minhas
costas que as pessoas fazem isso né
e ainda tenho medo de altura
vocês podem se perguntar por que raios
alguém tem medo de altura e é justamente
pular de paraquedas sabe vai passar e
acontece que na verdade eu queria chegar
em casa e depois tentar fazer uma
experiência de realidade virtual que eu
possa reproduzir essa experiência eu
queria entender o potencial dessa
tecnologia os limites dela e ver o
quanto que é o conseguir chegar perto
essa experiência na realidade virtual
então esse foi o primeiro de uma série
de experimentos que eu fiz usando
realidade virtual para ver onde é que
ela consegue nos chegar onde ela
consegue nos levar
na saúde na educação na cultura
e são esses experimentos que eu vou
trazer aqui pra vocês mas antes pretende
começar a ficar todo mundo na mesma
página a gente vai falar aqui de
realidade virtual
ela é uma das três tecnologias e mercy
vaz que a gente pode chamar de idade
digitais e eu vou falar mas dela porque
eu tenho mais experiência mas saibam que
todas as conclusões que foi chegar aqui
vão servir para as outras também que
elas são tecnologias irmãs elas vão
evoluir junto então vamos começar o que
é afinal a realidade virtual à realidade
virtual em sua forma mais básica é um
óculos que você coloca na sua cabeça e
ele tem uma tela dentro dele
nessa tela mostra como se fosse um filme
pra você e pra onde você olha a câmera
de filme acompanha e até ela estava toda
sua visão como se você tivesse ele
dentro daquele filme vocês podem ter
visto esses óculos as formas mais
diversas parecem estréia os futuristas
assim mas são produtos que já existem
o legal dessa tecnologia é que diferente
de um cinema por exemplo quando vocês
vão ver um filme
vocês entendem que ela história você se
emociona com aquilo que estão vendo
vocês ficam imersos naquela ficção
só que na realidade virtual você é um
protagonista dessa história ela adiciona
um nível de imersão as outras mídias que
a gente conhece hoje
então você fica ainda mais mérito ainda
mais comovido o seu cérebro se engana
acha que você realmente está lidando do
filme e alguns sistemas de realidade
virtual você pode usar as mãos para
interagir se pode conversar com outras
pessoas a interagir com os personagens
caminhar pelos ambientes filmes e isso
tem um potencial enorme
vocês podem perguntar com todo direito a
porque a gente quer entrar no filme
porque a gente quer evoluir das telas
fazer uma coisa diferente
acontece que encontrei no mínimo 12
grandes áreas da indústria que já estão
usando realidade virtual de maneira
consolidada
então por exemplo na arquitetura uma
arquiteta ela consegue projetar o prédio
que ela vai construir depois e na
realidade fala consegue entrar dentro
desse prédio e analisar ele em escala
real como se estivesse dentro desse
prédio sem que o prédio saia da planta
eu mobiliário consegue mostrar os
apartamentos para clientes sem que o
prédio só é da planta
eles podem também inclusive escolher a
cor do piso dos móveis a organização de
tudo e chegar ao apartamento dos sonhos
na frente deles e também um designer
pode enxergar os produtos que ele está
fazendo ou as roupas que ele está
fazendo
antes que elas saiam do papel também de
muitos outros casos como por exemplo
você pode treinar astronautas para
decorar a estação espacial internacional
antes dele sair da terra ou mesmo
simular montanhas russas para fazer com
que você ande por uma experiência
fantástica no mundo qualquer outro
também reconstitui cenas do crime para
peritos forenses ou mesmo simular
cirurgias de maneira muito mais imersiva
muito mais realista do que com manequins
e alguns experimentos que eu podia ter a
honra de participar que a gente está
usando realidade virtual para promover o
autoconhecimento através de uma série de
testes de jogos psicológicos tarefas
game escadas ou também reproduziu uma
experiência uma viagem psicodélica sem
uso de substâncias psicoativas
mas colhendo os frutos disso ou mesmo
uma aula de realidade virtual em que a
gente produziu aqui no brasil e
disponibilizou gratuitamente para
ensinar alunos crianças adolescentes
jovens adultos de maneira muito mais
imersiva muito mais intuitiva mais
interativa e games cada do que outros
métodos de ensino à distância que acabou
colecionando um sorriso na universidade
hebraica de jerusalém e todos esses usos
todos esses casos eles não aconteceram
por acaso realidade virtual está sendo
tão usada porque em 2016 ou investimento
de 2.3 bilhões de dólares nessas
indústrias realidade virtual idade
aumentada receberão 2 com 3 bilhões de
dólares
vocês podem perguntar e da onde vem esse
dinheiro ele veio das maiores empresas
de tecnologia do mundo
ou seja hoje várias das maiores empresas
do mundo acrescidos a isso em 2017 mas 3
bilhões de dólares foram investidos em
realidade virtual e realidade aumentada
ou seja 12 anos 20 bilhões de reais
foram investidos nessas duas tecnologias
eu acho que essas empresas devem
acreditar nessa tecnologia
eu acho que elas estão aí pra ficar mas
saber dessas coisas e levou a me
perguntar a pergunta que realmente faz
sentido que eu quero realmente por aqui
com vocês que afinal qual é o real
propósito dessas tecnologias porque que
vale a pena investir 20 bilhões de reais
nelas para simular montanhas russas ou
como é que a gente pode usar realidade
virtual a resolver problemas concretos e
portanto mudar o nosso mundo e pra falar
dessa parte eu quero começar com a
história de uma pessoa brilhante que
tive o prazer de conhecer o pesquisador
chamada de harmonia brasileiro que aqui
no nordeste do brasil
lá no instituto do cérebro na cidade de
macaíba
ele trabalhou ao lado de miguel
nicolelis na equipe num projecto chamar
num projeto chamado projeto andar de
novo porque eles usaram tecnologias de
ponta como esses esqueletos de
neuroimagem para fazer um paciente
clássico desculpa um caso típico de
tetraplegia com perda total dos
movimentos das pernas dá os primeiros
passos de novo e inclusive sentiu o chão
e tudo isso controlado pela mente desde
agora uma coisa que poucas pessoas sabem
é que o treinamento neuromotor de seus
esqueletos usaram realidade virtual de
maneira com que o paciente enxergar as
próprias pernas se mexendo e que o
cérebro ele reagisse de acordo então
eles pegaram uma coisa que nunca tinha
sido feita antes em nenhum lugar do
mundo e usaram e realidade virtual para
fazer
o impossível se fez possível por causa
de uma inovação tecnológica
às vezes a gente esquece o quanto isso é
um padrão
eu fui atrás de outras casas em
realidade virtual é usada no contexto
sentido de pesquisas científicas e
acontece que ela já está sendo usado
desde 1978
este ano fazem 50 anos que a realidade
virtual já está sendo usada em contexto
de pesquisas científicas
pensa bem 20 anos antes da internet
sequer se popularizar
já tinham experimentos de realidade
virtual acontecendo se imaginam como é
que deveria serviços antes celulares e
todos esses anos eles combinaram em
várias pesquisas que eu acabei indo mais
a fundo e descobri que a cidade fortal é
usada nas pesquisas porque você consegue
reproduzir qualquer set experimental ao
invés de montar uma maquete um
laboratório você consegue controlar
qualquer variável do ambiente em tempo
real podendo testar virtualmente
qualquer coisa e produzir tratamento de
maneira muito mais imersiva muito mais
limitado do que usando telas como a
gente já tem usado e todas as
características levaram pra diversas
pesquisas
centenas de pesquisas mais diversas
áreas da saúde como psicologia
neurologia nutrição fisioterapia
telessaúde e outras áreas além de áreas
afins como comunicação engenharias
design jornalismo assim por diante
e essas pesquisas portanto elas
resultaram em tratamentos de saúde que
eu considero brilhantes como por exemplo
você pode usar realidade virtual para
tratamento de dor crônica em pacientes
possam instalar sem uso de fármacos
você pode usar realidade virtual para
exercícios de fisioterapia de maneira
muito mais games cada muito mais
intuitivo aumentando a adesão eo esforço
dos pacientes ou também para tratamento
de transtorno de estresse pós traumático
da dependência química tratamento
complementar de alzheimer de autismo e
deficiências visuais ou outros
tratamentos como alguns que estão
estudando neste momento em que a gente
quer colocar pacientes com ansiedade e
com depressão pra fazer uma viagem
no mundo usando a realidade virtual
enquanto a gente usa neuroestimulação
não invasiva para treinar o cérebro dos
pacientes acolherem os estímulos
positivos e sentirem cada vez menos
sintomas de ansiedade e depressão
a longo prazo proponho uma forma de
tratamento complementar 1 seguindo o
mesmo princípio a gente está estudando
agora colocar pacientes com transtornos
alimentares
cercados de corridas virtuais crueldade
e aí treinar o cérebro deles com a mesma
técnica de neuroestimulação a inibe as
áreas cerebrais relacionadas com a
dependência pela comida propondo uma
forma de tratamento complementar para
transtornos alimentares
mas ok para responder realmente qual o
real propósito das tecnologias
eu precisava explorar fora do contexto
laboratorial fora da área das pesquisas
encontrei casos interessantes mas eu
queria trazer para vocês como por
exemplo uma experiência de realidade
virtual para fazer com que você troca de
sexo com outra pessoa promovendo
igualdade de gênero na pele a fazer com
que você tenha mais empatia com relação
a esse assunto globalmente importante ou
mesmo a experiência da digital e você
tem que ser a uma árvore dentro de uma
floresta sendo desmatado a fazer com que
você sinta o impacto da produção de bens
em massa ou também uma experiência
realidade virtual que levou líderes
econômicos e políticos do mundo a viver
um dia como se fossem refugiados
políticos
promovendo empatia com relação àquelas
minorias desfavorecidas ou se já o
projeto que eu tive a oportunidade de
participar porque a gente levou
realidade virtual para um hospital
público aqui de porto alegre
o tratamento de câncer de crianças na
ala de oncologia infantil
então a gente desenhou com ela brincou
com elas e construir uma experiência
digital para que elas fossem astronautas
por onde pudessem viajar no espaço
sideral que elas mesmos construíram quem
trabalha com o colégio infantil sabe o
quão difícil pode ser tirar um sorriso
de uma criança que está passando para as
dificuldades
naquela sala aquela sala de hospitais
naquela situação de quarentena e o
importante pode ser isso o tratamento
delas mas foi um dos momentos mais
emocionantes da minha vida
e foi também um dos momentos que eu
entendi o real propósito por trás dessas
tecnologias e fazer algo que nunca tinha
sido feito antes se tornar possível
então sabendo de tudo isso que eu queria
dizer quando falei para vocês que as
realidades digitais elas poderiam mudar
o nosso mundo o que eu queria dizer na
verdade é que a gente pode usar elas
para ajudar mais de 260 milhões de
pessoas com ansiedade ou mesmo para
ajudar mais de 300 milhões de pessoas
com depressão ou como forma de
tratamento complementar realidade
virtual para ajudar aproximadamente 40%
da população global que pode estar
enfrentando dificuldades com sobrepeso e
obesidade
isso além de outras patologias com
dependência química fobias vencer os
nossos medos vencer os nossos vícios
treinamento neuromotor e assim por
diante
sessenta estou falando aqui de uma
tecnologia que já está nos ajudando a
enfrentar vários dos maiores problemas
que o mundo tem hoje
então esse é o real propósito delas mas
quando eu falei para vocês que as
realidades digitais poderão mudar o
nosso mundo
desculpa eu me enganei pesquisa que elas
já estão mudando nosso mundo porque
todos dizemos que a trouxe no passado no
presente
eu queria trazer reflexão para vocês de
como essas tecnologias vão ser daqui a
cinco anos como ela não podemos ajudar
que já poder fazer com elas aqui há
cinco anos dez anos 15 anos
pensem por exemplo como é que era o
celular de vocês
há 15 anos atrás ele era mais parecido
com um tijolo do que uma folha de papel
só podia jogar o jogo da cobrinha nele e
o preço por desempenho era muito muito
muito mais alta
talvez daqui a 15 anos os óculos de
realidade virtual não ser tão finas
quanto óculos de sol ou mesmo lentes de
contato e possam reproduzir
o ambiente ainda mais imersivos
intuitivos aumentando o potencial das
tecnologias e por um preço muito muito
menor permitindo inclusive o uso
doméstico
então queria convidar vocês aí como
pesquisadores como profissionais e como
cidadãos
sabendo de tudo isso quando forem pensar
qual é o futuro das nossas realidades
pensa em como a gente pode usar essas
tecnologias que a gente tem hoje é
aprimorar realidade que a gente tem hoje
explore e 9 e vocês vão ser nós vamos
construir seu futuro
muito obrigado